let me ask uh by way of recommendations
i think a lot of people are curious
about this kind of stuff what three
books
technical or fiction or philosophical or
anything really
had an impact on your life and
and or you would recommend besides of
course your book
there's one book i wish everyone could
read i'm not sure if you've read it it's
actually a children's book like a young
adult book
it's called the giver yes
and it is the book that kids in school
read now and i only
sorry that that's not that's wow uh
sorry that that caught me off guard uh
so when i first
came to this country i didn't speak much
it's really what made me
uh it had a profound impact on my life
and i'm at a really important moment
because they they give it to
kids like i think middle school i think
or absolutely something like that i'm so
surprised you've even heard of this book
yeah so
they give but like it's the value of
giving the right book to a person at the
right time
uh i was as because it's very accessible
do we want to share what the story is
without spoiling it
uh yeah you can without spoiling right
it's well it follows this boy
in this very utopic society that's like
perfect it's been all clean cut and made
perfect actually
and as he kind of comes of age he starts
realizing something's wrong with his
world
and so it's part of that question are we
going to evolve this i mean this isn't
what's there but it made me wonder you
know are we evolving to a better place
is there a day when we can eliminate you
know poverty and hunger and crime
and sickness in this book they pretty
much have in the society that the boy's
in
and sort of follows him and he becomes
the chosen one to
be like a receiver the giver is the old
wise man who
retains some of the harshness of the
outside world so that he can advise the
people
as the sort of boy comes of age and is
chosen for the special role he finds the
world isn't what he expects
and i don't know about you but it was so
profound for me because
it jolts you out of reality it's like oh
my god what am i doing here i'm just
going with the flow
with my society how do i think outside
the box and the confines of my society
which surely carries negative things
with it that we don't realize today
yeah and also and the flip side of that
is if you do take a step outside the box
on occasion
uh what's the psychological burden of
that
like is that is is that your is that a
step you want to take
is that the journey you want to take
what is that life like
i don't know i felt like from the book
you have to take it i found from the
book i never thought like
now that you're saying it i see what
you're saying the burden is huge but
i always feel like the answer is yes you
absolutely want to know what's out
what's outside but you can't do that if
you're very it's hard to be objective
about your own reality
yeah it's a very human instinct but uh
it also the book kind of shows that uh
it has an effect on you and this
it's a really interesting question about
our society and taking a step out
it's by uh lois lowry i think
is how you pronounce it i really do hope
everyone created it is a young adult
book but it's still
it's incredibly i'm really glad i only
read it because my kids got it for
school
i just thought okay well why don't i
just see what this is about and i just
wow
yeah yeah i i think it's also the value
of education i think
i think i'm surprised you mentioned i've
never really mentioned to anybody
i'm sure a lot of people had some
experience like me and maybe
it's a generational thing though because
like the book came out i think in the
90s so
if you're older than like me that book
didn't exist when we were in middle
school so
i just do think a lot of people won't
have heard of it but it's an interesting
question of like
those books i mean i'm reminded often
i suppose the same is true with other
subjects but books
are special at the early age like middle
school maybe early high school
this those can change like the direction
of your life
and also certainly teachers
they can change completely the direction
of life there's so many stories about
uh teachers of mathematics teachers of
physics
of uh any kind of subjects basically
changing the direction of a human's life
that's like not to get on the
uh the whole almost like a political
thing but
you know we uh we undervalue teachers
uh it's a special it's a special
position that they hold
that's so true yeah well i do have two
other books or two other things
one is something i came across just a
few days ago actually
it's actually a film called picture a
scientist
and when you picture a scientist you
probably don't picture the
women and women of color in this film
and it is a way to get outside your box
i really think everyone interested in
science even just peripherally should
watch this because it is
shocking and sobering at the same time
and it talks about how
well i think one of the messages across
is you know we really are
like i don't know if we're hardwired to
just like people like ourselves
but we're excluding a lot of people and
therefore a lot of great ideas
by not being able to think outside of
how we're all stereotyping each other
so it's it's it's hard to kind of convey
that and you can just say oh yeah i want
to be more diverse i want to be more
open
but it's a nearly impossible problem to
solve and the movie really helps
open people's eyes to it this book i put
third because
unlike the giver people may not want to
read it it's not as relevant but
when i was in my early 20s i went to
this big
this like 800 people large conference
call
uh run by the wilderness canoe
association
in my hometown of toronto and there's a
family friend there who
i met and he said read this book it'll
change your life
and it actually changed my life and it
was a book called
sleeping island by an author pg downs
who
just coincidentally lived in this area
lived in the boston area he was a
teacher
i think at a private school and every
summer he would go to canada
with a canoe often by himself and he
wrote this book
maybe in the 40s or 50s about a trip he
took in the late 1930s
and it was i was just shocked that even
at that time although that was a long
time ago
there were large parts of canada that
were untouched by white people
and he went up there and interacted like
with the natives he called the book
and had a subtitle that was called
there's something like
journey in the barren lands and when you
go up north in canada you pass the tree
line
just like on a mountain if you hike up a
mountain you get so far north there
aren't any trees
and he wrote eloquently about the land
and about being out there
there weren't even any maps of the
region like in that time
and i just thought to myself wow like
that you could just take the summer off
and explore by canoe
and go and see what's out there and it
led to me
just doing that that very thing of
course it's different now
but going out to where the road ends and
putting the canoe in the water and just
well we had to have a plan we didn't
just
explore but go down this river rivers
with rapids and
travel over lakes and portages and just
really live
so just really explore screw it that
doesn't like it doesn't or just use from
a topo map from a topographical map
from the library and those things um
there were scary elements about of it
out of it but part of the
excitement or the joy or the desire was
to be scared
like was to go out there and have live
on the edge and persevere
yeah and persevere yeah
you